foreign
town the Great and Powerful Houston
Texas and talk to Dear Marie what's up
Marie
hey Dr John how are you doing party and
how about you
oh I'm hanging in there I'm not partying
Okay I lied to you hey so what's
happening what's going on
um so my question is I want to know how
to stop taking my resentfulness on my
kids for their dad leaving and getting a
new family because I want to grow a
healthy relationship with my kids and
stop being so frustrated how do you take
out your resentfulness against your
husband on your kids
it's mostly I just get
just get treated because I'm
and I just you know at them a lot
so
what happened with your husband
um take your time take your time you're
all good huh
what happened with your husband
we were together about 15 years
I mean we had you know dated for five
before getting married and
had our first
child
um about five years after getting
married
and he was getting older and
obviously I was getting older or closer
to 30 and I had always heard of health
concerns about having children older so
I approached my husband about
possibly having another kid because we
had already talked about having two to
three and that's kind of what we both
wanted
um he
voices concerns about you know money and
providing for the kids
and I pretty much just
ignored his concerns
and I ended up getting off of my birth
control and then getting pregnant with
our daughter
so here we are he lost trust in me yeah
hmm
it's one of those catch-22s where you
have the most precious thing in the
world is your daughter and you wouldn't
take that back for a second at the same
time it's a pretty significant violation
right
oh yeah I'm super shameful yeah it's
both and right you got this beautiful
gift out of it and that's tough just
tough on on that's tough weight on a
relationship so yeah he says he can't
trust you to see does he bail
no he's so he stays around and we you
know try and work it out
right before her first birthday and my
son starts kindergarten he decides to
leave and he
leaves the house
um and then that's that's 20 20.
um so I'm doing kindergarten by myself
my son ends up getting quarantined and
for his birthday and his sister's
birthday so their dad missed their
birthdays because you couldn't see them
because we were quarantined
um and the quarantine kind of woke him
up
um so he came back and said he actually
wanted a relationship with his kids
which I'm so grateful for so he's in
their life okay
but but your marriage is over I I want
to be honest with you there was things
long before this
um I won't sugarcoat it and I'm not
going to kick you while you're down
either this is this is a significant
betrayal and
there was other things going on
Fair
there's other issues going on
we communicated our needs at all okay
yeah
you must have been in honors classes
there in Houston so yes you are correct
I'm sure certain so
here's why I asked you to tell me that
story
just just in the process of telling that
story I want you to go back and listen
to this your whole body posture changed
from you from when you started the call
to when you ended it okay that's a story
that happened to you
and it's heartbreaking and you're gonna
grieve that for a long time
okay and did you play a role in that
yeah did he walk out on his family yeah
it's both in and as a as a guy who has
had trouble in his marriage over the
last 20 almost 21 years
um but I didn't walk away on my wife and
my kids do I judge him yeah I do but
also you know like that assigning a
percentage of weight in the situation
doesn't help anybody he's still gone
right yeah um is he remarried is he got
has he moved on with his life
yeah so he reads like within the last I
would say months got remarried okay
so so now it looks like a new nuclear
family well and so it looks like on
Instagram or whatever Facebook wherever
you posted stuff that everything's all
Rosy and great and you still got two
little Knuckleheads and you can't sleep
and you're exhausted and you gotta work
and all that stuff right it feels so
heavy
so I want to decouple
how you interact with your kids from the
grief you're feeling
with it with the loss and death of that
relationship
okay because it's easy for it to get all
all jumbled together
but how you honor your kids and how you
don't yell at your children how you
don't take out your grief on them or
make it their job to make you feel
better
um yeah that's critically important and
you're going to be frustrated by things
over and over and over as you raise
these kids and so learning right now
I am
nothing will ever impact the way I treat
them in fact it's my job to make sure
that those arrows hit me not them
not that they're not that I'm a
pass-through and those arrows hit my
kids through me right and so tell me
about a time you just lost it it's got
frustrated and lost it
oh it's it really is just centered
around
either food or like
television like
like if they misbehave or anything like
the repercussion is no TV time and then
it's just up there is that working
yeah no
it's not no all right so here's a simple
thing that I want you to transition in
your home okay
Step One is how old are these kids
oh almost eight and four okay okay
perfect I want you to take that
eight-year-old
and I want you to take that
eight-year-old somewhere special and you
and I both know that special for an
eight-year-old is like McDonald's or uh
somewhere like Waffle House is where I
take my kid but somewhere special a
local Diner or whatever
um there's a lot of rad local places in
Houston
and I want it to feel special for this
eight-year-old is it boy or a girl
a boy okay
um
if you can find somebody to watch your
four-year-old for an hour or two I think
to be really special
and when you get to this restaurant I
want you to do the best you can to
position yourself where you can put that
little boy's face in both of your hands
so not only can he absorb the fact that
Mommy's doing something special for us
all for me and for us too
but also
nothing in the world matters the phone
is in your purse everything is away and
it is you locking under that kid and
then he gets to feel it
and then you say Mommy's had her heart
broken
and
me and as you know Daddy moved out and
I'm just so sad and I've I've let my sad
turn into me yelling at you and I want
you to know that I'm so sorry
I want you to start there okay
I want you to do that at a much more
age-appropriate way for your
four-year-old okay yeah
and let that four-year-old know so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
create a daily practice where you are
putting your hands on the face of your
kids and looking them in the eye and be
almost obnoxiously long maybe five or
ten whole seconds to where it's kind of
weird for everybody
yeah and you'll notice your kid's
shoulders just drop
okay
the second thing is we're going to
switch the language in our house to you
punish them by saying all right no no TV
or you say if you do this then you you
don't get to watch TV we're going to be
done with that language
we're going to switch to
if you guys choose to get all your
chores done
then y'all are choosing to watch 30
minutes of television
and if you choose not to do your chores
then you're choosing not to do
television
strange choice but y'all can choose it
and they are going to test you on it and
you're just gonna have to hold firm and
then they kick and scream and cry and
you can go man I've been through way
worse I my marriage is gone you guys
can't hurt hurt my feelings
and what we're going to teach them very
very quickly is they have a lot of
choice in how good their day is or how
their day is
yeah okay
and it's going to take the pressure off
of you because you hate saying no no no
no no no no where do you all no you hate
that role yeah and that role doesn't
work
and you know you can beat your kids into
submission you can make them do things
because you're bigger than them
I'd much rather them begin to learn and
it's a pain
I'd rather them learn over the long haul
that they play a role in that family and
that they get to choose the the levels
of fun and joy they have in their house
right right and it might start with TV
and they just say well fine then we're
not doing it cool then they're going to
start opting they're going to choose to
not do a bunch of other stuff
yeah they're going to choose and not go
to birthday parties they're going to
choose to not they're making this choice
and I'm not and and I'm not taking any
of that blame do you see how the whole
thing dumps over it's not you against
them it's you cheering them on
see what I'm saying that's what I want
yeah and here's the other here's a big
piece here's number three
never yell at your kids
ever if you have to go for a walk walk
out the front door
when you yell their nervous system gears
up their ability to learn and take in
information is over
okay so it's it's wholly uneffective and
it terrifies Their little bodies
yeah I'm not one of these like
super Atomic woke parents I don't know
what that means but I'm not one of these
like just let the kids do whatever they
want whatever they feel that's all
nonsense
but I want to do things at work and when
I yell at a kid learning has ended
I want to scream at a kid their ability
to process information and actually
learn what I'm trying to teach them so
they can become great adults down the
road over over it ends
and so I'm never gonna yell at my kids
I'm not
I'm going to hold them accountable when
they make choices
I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna yell
yeah you
need to internalize this the greatest
gift you can give your kids is for you
to go see a counselor and get well
because you're not all right
yeah is that fair I have been yeah
you've been seeing somebody
yeah we're actually I don't know if
you've heard of the um like
yeah
yeah so we were going to try something
like that to see if that would help
stay plugged in with that counselor but
here's what I want you to say the next
time you go see your counselor I want
you to say I want to learn some tools
so that I can be more present in the
moment when I get frustrated and I don't
just fly off the handle
okay put your counselor on the spot to
not just sit there and talk for hours
about how you feel and how does it make
you feel and how does that make you feel
I need some tools I need some tools
okay
you have much more strength than you
believe you do is that fair
yeah okay last exercise can I give you a
homework assignment
yes yes sir
I want you to go um and you've heard me
do this if you've ever listened to the
show for very long you've heard me do
this a lot I want you to run by Lowe's
or Home Depot or maybe you have one in
your backyard
I want you to go buy a cinder block
and I want you to get some duct tape and
put it across that cinder block and I
want you to write
lying to my husband about birth control
and I want you to carry that around your
backyard for a little while until it
gets so heavy it might be one minute it
might be 20 minutes I don't know
I want you to go to you almost can't
carry it anymore and then I want you to
throw it down in the back corner of your
backyard tear that tape off and never
pick that brick up again
you've got to forgive Marie okay
and then I want you to see that little
four-year-old little girl I want you to
hug her so tight for the gift that she
is
yeah both in Fair
yes sir yeah
I'm really really proud of you this is
you saying I'm done with the way it has
been right
yeah yeah absolutely I want you to not
know
anything about your husband's New Life
block him on everything I don't want to
look at any pictures no going down the
same way I tell 18 year old boys don't
look at pornography I'm telling you
don't look at any of these photos
they're not real they're not real okay
yeah
she will understand how bad his farts
smell real quick she'll understand how
annoying he is when fill in the blank
real quick right
yeah yes
and the challenges that he had with
communication with you didn't suddenly
get fixed all of that will be reality
but I don't want you trailing them
around wondering about the life you
could have had
he laughed he left he left he left he
left
that hurts we gotta grieve we gotta sit
in sadness for a while
he moved on he went and remarried
and you're still stuck right in the
middle of all this
but we're not going to follow him around
we're gonna chase him around digitally
I'm glad he's still in the life of your
kids so you have to interact with him
great
but I'm not keeping up with anything
about their life and where they go on
vacation and what kind of new cars they
got I'm not keeping up with any of that
stuff
I'm gonna rebuild my life with my two
little kids and my mental health and my
emotional health and my physical health
I'm gonna rebuild my life here
thank you so much Murray I'm grateful
for you